hi i'm uh joseph doretti
i'm at the department of bioengineering
at ucla
i just wanted to thank the organizers
for having me uh to be able to
give a talk at this webinar
conference and i always like to start my
talk
with the fluorescence image that you see
on the screen right here
so this is a fluorescence image of a
sub nanoliter droplets formed using only
a pipette and microparticles
the objective of my talk is to to
convince you the audience that
using this lab on a particle technology
you can enable really any researcher to
perform
a single cell secretion assays
so i originally came from a
microfluidics background
and in this field we've seen over the
last really two decades or so that has
been a
very powerful tool and that specifically
it enables the creation of highly
uniform compartments
at the length scale of single biological
entities
so this includes things such as proteins
dna as well as single cells which i'll
be talking about mostly in this talk
and the real strength of this of this
technology
is that it gives you the capability to
take a
heterogeneous for example cell
population
um be able to look at individual cells
and study certain phenotypes and then be
able to
to identify or in some cases even
isolate
a rare sub types of these these
populations
i mean this has really been particularly
powerful
in areas such as the screening of cho
cells b
cells and hybridomas for for antibody
production
um this is uh of particular
importance uh now really with uh with
some of the
potential therapies for the uh covid19
being
monoclonal antibody therapies so being
able to select out clones that are
productive producers for example cho
cells is very useful
technique and there's also other uses
in areas such as doing functional t cell
analysis
and screening as well as ctc
secretion profiling and just to really
kind of summarize
some of the existing platforms out there
you have these kind of microstructured
uh devices that contain the cells
themselves so for example
microchambers or these kind of
nanopen some people call them that use
optoflytics to be able to manipulate
single cells into these these pens uh
microwell arrays
as well as micro droplets um i think
it's important also to note that
some of these platforms are more suited
for the
sorting applications so for example the
optofluidic platform
forms and the micro droplet platforms
are
a little more suited for for doing
actual sorting
and if you want to learn like in a
little bit more detail about
some of these technologies there's a
great review from a wrong fans group
that came out last year discussing
various microfluidic technologies for
for screening
cells based off of functional secretions
now say you want to use some of these
microfluidic platforms to
do single cell secretion assays whether
it be in your
lab or as a research project or
as part of a company so working in a
microfluidics lab
you kind of see how a lot of these
things actually work
first hand so for example you might see
a you might see a paper where you have a
nice clean microscope image of this
microfluidic device that
fabricates droplets it looks really
simple and straightforward
and seems really just kind of easy to
use
but realistically we know that this is
really
a simple device embedded in a much
larger chip
and if you wanted to fabricate one of
these chips yourself with your own
design
you need access to a high-tech clean
room facility
now assuming that you you have these
things and you're able to manufacture
a design that you want to use for your
project
then to actually use these for in most
cases you need access to
specialized and often expensive
equipment to actually
run these devices so this is several
barriers of entry to actually using this
technology
now say you don't want to go through all
the troubles and making a custom chip
but you want to kind of explore the
commercial options
and there are a number of commercial
platforms that
are available and particularly for doing
single cell antibody development
sphere fluidics is one company they have
the cytomine
this is a droplet-based platform for
sorting and
cells of interest based off their
secretion pro uh secretions
uh berkeley lights is another platform
this is uh uses it utilizes optoflytics
in order to to look at cells and look at
their
production over time now
i i have to say that these are very
functional
platforms that are really well at doing
what they're
developed to do now i would like
to kind of argue that there is a a big
kind of caveat for these systems and
just to kind of put that in perspective
i am currently at ucla which is one of
the largest public institutes
in the in the world and we do not have
access to either of these technologies
which to me means that that a lot of
people actually do not have access to
these technologies and that there is
definitely a barrier to entry to having
for
researchers to actually use technology
such as this
so although these are very capable
platforms
i would like to argue that they are not
yet ubiquitous and not all
researchers have access to these
technologies
so what the question i want to bring up
then is
is really so how do we create a
technology that is accessible to more
people
to perform these assays and to kind of
rephrase that
question a little bit the the question
really is can we perform these same
single self secretion assays but using
only common lab equipment
and what do i mean by common lab
equipment
by that i mean really common so
micropipettors
vortexer centrifuge well plates even
and this can also include more
technically complex
instruments so things like such as flow
cytometers for example so flow
cytometers have been around for
multiple decades they are well
established in many research
labs pretty much any research institute
you go to should have
some sort of flow core on campus with
many of these flow cytometers
available many companies have these many
clinical clinical labs have these so
although it's more technically complex
it is a very accessible technology and i
would consider it common
so how could we perform this assay using
these these common lab
equipment well so let me let me kind of
kind of bring it down to what are the
requirements that we would
kind of necessitate to properly perform
these assays
well the first thing we need to do is be
able to create uniform compartments
so we need compartments so that we can
isolate single cells
and also so that we can retain any
secreted product
with that specific cell we need uniform
compartments because if
we're trying to differentiate say
different cells that are producing
different amounts of proteins
we need to make sure that the reaction
volume is very similar in order to be
able to properly differentiate
their production rates the second
retirement that we
need is ideally we have some solid
substrate to perform reactions
and so this is sometimes can be
something like a capture capture bead
that has capture antibodies that
specifically bind the proteins of
interest
and then once you have that the last
thing you need to be able to do is to be
able to read out and potentially sort
and hide throughput so this could be
through use of a secondary fluorescent
tag
specific to that protein and as i was
kind of alluding to before
if you want to do sorting you'd want it
to be compatible with the flow cytometer
system
and so compatible usually it dictates
that it needs to be
small enough to actually fit through the
the nozzle of the device of the of the
flow cytometer so less than 100 microns
and
it also needs to be in an aqueous phase
it can't be an oil it can't be in any
other
system so you can't put droplets through
a standard flow cytometer you need to
have
some other way of reading out and
and processing your your your sample
so our kind of solution that we came up
with
in our lab is this this concept of lab
on a particle
and the idea is quite simple and
and seems straightforward but took quite
a lot of time to develop
and the idea is that you could take
these if you take 3d structured
particles that have
unique shape and unique material
properties
can you spontaneously create uniform
compartments
in order to isolate say in this case for
example
cells of interest and any of these these
compartments or droplets formed by these
microparticles we refer to them as
tropicals
and we've been developing this system
over the last
four years now and we've uh here's just
kind of a
blanket view view summary of these
technologies we actually just released
quite a few pre-prints
in the last couple months on various
approaches that we have used
to create these these tropicals
i won't go into all these in detail i
just wanted to kind of
share that there is a multiple ways to
to
to create these lab on a particle
systems today i'll be focusing mostly on
on this work that i
i spearheaded which is using these
particles for doing
a single cell secretion assays
so i i kind of alluded to that we need
so we have these particles we need them
to be highly uniform
and we need them to have very distinct
shapes in this case i argue we need to
have some cavity to
maintain a cell inside of so how can we
create these and how can we create these
uniformly and high throughput
so although i argue that we don't want
to have to use
special equipment or say microfluidics
in the
end assay perhaps we can utilize it
up front in order to fabricate materials
that can then be distributed to other
people
and so that's exactly what we did so we
used a microfluidic droplet generator
in this case we're injecting a uv
cross-linkable
peg polymer phase with this it's it's
nice that it's very modifiable you can
add
different reactive groups such as a
biotin or
say a peptide sequence such as rgd that
allows for cell adhesion
in the other phase we have a dextran
polymer phase
so we mix these together we generate
droplets with these
and if you wait just a few seconds they
actually
they'll undergo phase separation so this
is these polymers are unique in that
they're an aqueous two-phase system
and if you tune the polymer
concentration just right you can get
this very distinct morphology
where you have a outer peg spherical
drop
and then a smaller spherical dextran
component maintained within that that
larger droplet
that's just barely touching the surface
now if you imagine you have these
droplets with these morphology
if you excite them with uv light to
cross-link the peg phase
and then wash to remove the oil and
transfer them back into water
you're left with these these sort of
bowl
or kind of suspendable microparticle
shaped
or microwell shaped particles that have
an exposed cavity
and the nice thing is you can create a
lot of these particles
and high throughput and then store them
for later use
and the point i want to kind of
emphasize here is that
in terms of doing the assays that i will
talk about further in this presentation
there will be no more microfluidics
so we are using the microfluidics up
front in order to fabricate these
smart biomaterials that we can then use
as part of a assay that is compatible
with just
simple common laboratory equipment
so great how can we actually
kind of meet the requirements that i set
forth earlier so the first thing is we
need to be able to create uniform
compartments
and uh the way we figured out to do this
quite
quite simply actually is if you if you
take a suspension of these particles
and you take some oil and surfactant and
if you just agitate it by pipetting
you can imagine that you will create
small smaller and smaller
water and oil droplets until eventually
you get
to the size of the particles themselves
and what we have determined is that
the droplets will actually stay at the
size of the particles due to
some energy energy minimization effects
and any excess fluids will be
partitioned into these smaller satellite
droplets
and so here's a bright field image kind
of showing what this looks like
experimentally so you'll see these
uniform larger
droplets that are that are formed with
these these particles
and you should see a sea of background
uh satellite droplets
so this is really hard to see so i'm
actually going to go back to that
that original image that i showed so
here are is a fluorescent image of the
same thing
so here the particles are stained with a
red dye and there is a diet that is
added into the water phase in order to
help
visualize exactly what's going on so the
first thing we see is that the
droplets formed with these particles are
highly uniform
we see that there remains a accessible
cavity that
holds a fluid volume that again is
uniform
and although that we see some cases we
get maybe doublets of these particles
formed
in a single droplet when we look at the
population as a whole we see that these
doublets are actually
a quite small fraction of the population
and then if we look at the uniformity of
the
population we see that all the droplets
formed with these particles
are very uniform so cv diameter is a
diameter cvs of about four percent which
is comparable even with state-of-the-art
uh droplet microfluidic systems
so great we've met our first requirement
we can create uniform compartments and
we can do it with
just a pipette with the simple common
lab
equipment so how do we how can we
associate cells with these
so one thing we notice when working with
these particles is that
if you seed them into a well plate you
can kind of imagine that due to their
morphology they actually tend to settle
with
their cavities exposed upright so
exploiting this effect what we found we
could do is that you can see
the particles into it just a normal well
plate once they have settled and reached
the bottom of the well plate
you can then seed cells in in this case
we have particles that are modified with
a
integrand binding peptide sequence or gd
and we're using cho cells as a kind of a
test line
and if we seed the cells in and adjust
the concentration what we see is we can
load cells into the particle cavities
that they will attach
and if you tune the concentration of the
cells
you can actually ensure that
statistically you will have either
one or fewer cells per particle so in
this case we want to ensure that there's
a single cell per particle
and when we look at this over a range of
concentrations we see that this very
closely follows poisson loading
statistics
now a keen observer will note that not
all the cells will
end up in the particles and that is an
important point
we find that approximately 20 percent of
the cells actually end up
associating with the particles
themselves but actually if we compare to
a lot of the state-of-the-art systems
such as droplet microfluidic systems
that rely on using
capture beads co-encapsulated with the
droplets that
due to the double poisson loading
effects with these systems they actually
also have uh not not uh
not perfect loading efficiencies um so
this is actually
somewhat comparable to the existing
state-of-the-art systems
and can definitely be improved on so
we can load ourselves into these
particles they have these exposed
cavities which are great for
for holding them what happens when we
then try and emulsify them so create
tropicals with them
so what we see is that the one the cells
actually cell stay
well associated with the particles
themselves and
what we also note is that over a
significant duration of time they
actually stay fairly viable
in this case the oils that we're using
are oils and surfactants that have been
well studied in the droplet microfluidic
space
and are well known to be biocompatible
have high oxygen transport
another important thing to note too is
that we we rarely see
cells that are attached to the outside
of the particle but we see cells that
are
very well maintained inside the
particles and our
kind of ongoing theory is that the
cavity itself
acts as a as a shear shelter to protect
the the cells from any shear that's
going on during the emulsification step
which
could also provide benefits for
improving the viability of the cells as
well so
our cells are alive so what happens if
we we want to recover them say we want
to
kind of isolate certain cells of
interest
so what we can do actually is we can
once we've emulsified
them into oil you can actually break the
emulsion so in this case you use a
a mild biocompatible detergent to
coalesce the drops and wash away the oil
and then when we recover the cells with
the particles after this
what we see is that one cell still stay
attached
and two we can actually we can actually
watch these these cells grow over time
so in this case we have a 24 hour
48 hour and 72 hour time point um you
can see
these like initial starting colonies are
actually expanding over time and at a
certain point they will actually
overwhelm the particle and they will
kind of engulf it and then
spread onto the whatever surface that's
below it so in this case they were
seated in a well plate and so they'll
actually expand onto the well plate
afterwards and when we compare this with
just seeding into
a a well played as a control we see that
the relative growth of these cells is
actually quite
comparable so great we have a system
that we can create compartments
we can keep ourselves alive we can
recover them afterwards and expand them
out
so how do we perform a functional
secretion assay
so starting where we left off we have
our cells and our particles
and one unique thing about this system
is that these particles aren't fixed so
you can actually
resuspend them so in this case you can
pipet them and recollect them into a
conical tube
and you can imagine that while the cells
are adhering to the particles
in this time they might be secreting
molecules which will be creating a
background signal
but uniquely with our system we can
actually just do simple
centrifuging and washing steps to remove
this background
we can then utilize some of the
functionality of our particles so in
this case
we have biotin groups embedded into the
particles themselves
we can add streptavidin and then in this
case we're linking
a biotinylated capturing antibody that's
specific to
human igg fc
and once you do this we can then
immediately uh emulsify it into
these tropicals uh and so this what does
what this lets us do is
it lets us compartmentalize the cell um
any secreted molecules in this case will
then attach to the particle surface
due to the capture antibodies and then
once we've incubated long enough to
be able to get enough high enough signal
we can then transfer it back into water
as i discussed before
and then we can just label it with
fluorescent secondary antibodies
uh and so what this kind of looks like
experimentally so here's a
microscope image with a bright field
image
merged with some fluorescent images and
so you'll see that with
these these are anti-iolites gradient
chosel line
and what you'll see is that there are
several particles that have single cells
associated with them
and it's only these particles really
that we see these fluorescent signal
from the
captured antibodies and when we
looked at the system so kind of
analyzing just with that with a
microscope
some matlab code that if we increase the
incubation time we see that the
intensity of these fluorescent
secondaries also
increases with that time indicating that
one
we can actually generally quantify the
amount
of secreted molecules from these cells
but two also it's very interesting that
we see that
it's not a single peak we see or it's
not a
very sharp peak we see a very large
distribution in the productivity of
these
of these cells which is supposed to be a
cell line indicating that there is
a lot of functional variability in these
in these cells
so kind of taking a step back i think
when we
when we look at the system we really
wanted to verify that this is working
the way we think it
um we we think it's working
and so particularly we were curious to
see if we take the same system
and put it into a bulk suspension so in
this case we are not going to do
any of the encapsulation steps
and see what happens and so when we
perform the assay this way
what we see is that the particles with
cells
indeed have a fluorescent signal
associated with them
which is expected uh but kind of
as expected as well we see that a lot of
particles without cells
also have signal signal associated with
them
and if you look at these over
if you look at this over a population
what you'll see is that there is
significant crosstalk
and there's an overlap in the signal
from these populations meaning that
you're not able to really distinctly
determine on from a single cell
resolution
to quantify the the amount of secretions
being produced
so just doing this kind of same study
again with the
tropical system we break we wash we
label
we now see that only the particles the
cells have signal
and then when we analyze this as a
population as a whole we see that there
is
in in this case no crosstalk in the
system so great we have a
a secretion assay there is able to
analyze
single cells without crosstalk
and so the next part as i discussed
earlier on is we want to be able to
analyze as well as sort and high
throughput with the system
so what we did to really kind of test
this system even further is we took two
different cell populations
um so the antibody producing cho cells
that i
i showed before as well as a cell line
that
does not produce any human antibodies we
label them with their own separate
cell tracker so that we could kind of
trace them through the experimental
process
we then performed the assay as we had
before we did the labeling
and then we ran them through a
commercial flow cytometer
and so what we saw when we did this is
that so this is an image of the pre
pre-sorted sample we see that
the particles with the cells that should
not be producing antibodies have
this is in this case blue there is no
signal associated with them there's no
green fluorescent signal from the
antibodies however the
in this case magenta colored stained
cell
which is an antibody producing chocolate
we do see a distinct signal associated
with this
and when we uh when we ran this
through a flow sorter and selected our
population based off of
the antibody fluorescent signal we saw
that we were actually able to isolate
this subtype that we spiked in and
we looked at this over a range of
different dilutions so going from
anywhere from one out of five
cells containing the antibody producing
cho cells
down to much more dilute cases of one to
a thousand
and even in this this much more dilute
case we still see that we're able to
sort with
a fairly high purity above 80 percent
based off the secreted molecules and i
guess an another important thing to note
here too is
for this last condition too we had to
screen over a hundred thousand cells
within
a uh single within a single screen in a
in a single day um so it is very high
throughput
system um but this is really just kind
of a control test to show that
uh this uh this assay and the sorting is
is behaving as we expect um we wanted to
go a little bit further and see if we
could do something maybe a little more
interesting on a functional level so
what we did is we took this
antibody producing chocolate line we
performed the assay
and then we again ran it through a flow
sorter and we
looked at the population of events of
with particles with cells and having
positive positive antibody signal
and you'll notice if you kind of look at
this this top section of the graph that
there's actually a sizable population of
cells that are not
producing antibody so no longer
secreting these molecules and we noticed
this earlier on too when we're doing
microscopy analysis
and we and we did some further analysis
to verify that this is
not due to due to viability or things
like that but there's actually a
subpopulation within our
our our global cell line that is not
effectively secreting the molecules
of interest so what we did is we we
selected two different
populations ones that are all producing
these are all producers so these are the
condition where we're just selecting out
ones that
are producing antibodies and so we're
trying to get rid of the population
that's no longer
producing and we also took a even a step
further and selected out a
a higher tier of this subpopulation so
top 20 percent
of producing cells we then expanded
these over a little over a week
and then we did a well-played elisa
assay
to see what our production levels were
and so when we compare this with our
pre-sort sample
we actually saw that in the case of the
top 20 condition we were able to achieve
about a 50 increase in production and
this is with four
biological samples uh replicated so
all all performed in parallel and we
actually see for one of our our
subpopulation
we achieved about a 58 increase in in
the production levels
so it was great so we were able to
actually uh probe based off of a
functional phenotype so in this case
secreted molecules
were able to sort based off that uh and
actually show downstream that we're
actually able to isolate a sub
uh some population of interest that is
doing this and this is all with this
standard lab equipment
so uh i think a good point to bring up i
i showed that slide earlier on with the
various microfluidic systems
and my my first main point was that well
we want to create a system that is more
accessible to researchers
so really emphasizing the fact that we
want it to be
compatible with any standard lab
equipment
but how does the performance of our
system actually stack up against these
systems
well if we kind of consider these these
examples here i'm just taking
the amount of cells that you can screen
per day as a metric
uh so for some of these cases so
microchambers and maybe optofluidic
systems the
uh the throughput is maybe a little bit
less there are other advantages to these
systems which
i don't have time to go into detail
about
some of these systems too uh the cell
recovery as i mentioned before is
is quite difficult so these
microchambers and microwave arrays are
not really well suited to sorting and
high throughput
and another thing to maybe consider is
uh
the idea of cell compatibility um so a
lot of these systems are
theoretically compatible with suspension
and adherent cells
um with droplet microfluidic approaches
they are not
very well suited for adherent cell types
as you can imagine they have no surface
to adhere to and depending on how long
you have to incubate the cells for this
is not
ideal situation now if we compared it
with our system
so our current our current system we
actually see that we
can achieve throughputs that is uh
comparable to the state of our
microfluidic platforms and part of the
reason why
that we can do this is due to the fact
that we
can analyze and sort using
using existing fax machines so
flow cytometers so these have been tuned
over the last
several decades to be very
high-throughput machines for
for analyzing micro
objects or cells the other thing too is
that
the way that we're forming these
compartments is is really
massively done in parallel it's not a
serial
approach you're not manually pipetting
single cells you're not uh
sequentially generating droplets in this
case so this allows us to parallelize a
lot
of the of the workflow uh
and if i kind of come back to this try
over to the right here with the cell
compatibility
interestingly our system currently is a
little bit
kind of opposite of these other droplet
microfluidic platforms in that it's
very well suited for adherent cell types
so currently we've been testing the
system with
cells that can adhere via rgd binding
sites
but i think i really need to emphasize
here that this is just a
really a first generation of the system
and
some of our more recent work and what we
kind of project
in the near future is that if we address
a couple things so
making say particles smaller to be
compatible with
uh with smaller nozzles on flow
cytometers could increase the throughput
of the analysis and sorting step
improving the efficiency of loading
could also
significantly bump up our our our
throughput capabilities
for for screening and
already we've been exploring other
approaches to
make this system more compatible with a
larger variety of cell types
so whether it be b cells or
t cells or other non-adherent cell types
and have had some limited uh we've had
some success so far but i'm not going to
go into too much detail but
we really see that this is a a platform
that can grow
and can be can really even outperform
all the existing
state-of-the-art technologies
so just to kind of summarize uh what i
discussed today so we've created this
platform that allows you to take this
this reagent so a particle microparticle
reagent
that you can seed into a well plate and
isolate single cells you can form
compartments with them by simple
agitation steps
allow cells to secrete and capture these
secretions onto the particles
you can then transfer these back into a
water phase that is compatible with flow
cytometers
label them with a fluorescent secondary
antibody
and sort in high throughput and really
kind of just
painting the vision for this this
platform this technology
what we really see is we have a platform
that allows us to take cells
with interesting and functional
phenotypes
we can use these microparticles
we can combine them with existing lab
infrastructure and
can use them to perform these very
quantitative
high quality assays on single cells
and i think a really important thing to
note too
with this technology is that this is
something that's very easy to distribute
so
i mean already we're sending these these
particles to collaborators
it's very easy to ship it's much
different from having to
create a altogether
equipment or machine that you have to
move and install into a new location
and the infrastructure we do use that's
maybe more complex are already well
established
in existing labs so so testing out and
adopting this technology
there really is a very low hurdle
compared to other systems
i think this is actually really
pertinent now where it's
more difficult than ever to travel where
we're trying to limit interactions with
with others to
kind of reduce the um the spread of
copa 19 and i think perhaps especially
too with
some of the applications of the system
being particularly suited for
potential therapy so for example for the
production or isolation of cells
producing neutralizing antibodies
this could really be a really powerful
approach that
many people could use and kind of aside
from these the single cell secretion
assays
we really don't see this as a kind of
one-off
tool we really see this as just the
beginning
of a of a larger tool set
that can be used to to really probe the
limits
of biology so looking at all single
entities so
for example looking at proteins at low
concentrations or even single proteins
using these microgel droplet elisa
assays
or perhaps looking at nucleic acids so
doing digital nucleic acid
assays with these lab on a particle
systems
and if i had to summarize this whole
presentation and one slide
and maybe this is also particular for
the lab automation folks
if you take your 1536 well plate which
handles
fluid volume in the range of one to ten
microliters
uh if i could tell you that you could
have a reagent system a particle reagent
system
that allows you to create compartments
that are a thousand times smaller
and that you can create more than a
thousand times more compartments
and you could sort using only
existing lab infrastructure what would
you do with these systems
and download
for this work uh professor dino dicarlo
my lab mates
robert di mateo mark monzee professor
robert namaso one of our collaborators
as well as many others who have worked
on other aspects of this project that i
was not able to
discuss in detail but if you want to
learn more about what we're working on
you can check out our website at
biomicrofluidics.com if you look on the
bottom right
or if you have if you want to reach out
to me you can always reach out to me on
on linkedin and with that i want to
thank you all for your attention
and and all the best